OK. Now, I know you've all done
the reading for the week
already and I know that you
remember everything I was
saying at the last
minute before break,
but just for my sake, I'll
just remind you that we were
just wrapping up
talking about the March on
Washington for
Jobs and Freedom,
and the assassination of
the four little girls in
Birmingham, Alabama,
essentially spending the
time, much of our
last week of lecture,
dealing, dealing with these
iconographic individuals and
moments in Martin
Luther King and the March on
Washington, and trying to
unravel a lot of the more
familiar historiography
or history around these
individuals.
What I want to do today is
to continue in that work of
reframing the civil rights
movement iconic figures and
spend today's lecture
talking about Malcolm X.
Now a couple of caveats,
maybe just one caveat,
to begin with is
that for this week's,
this week's lectures are
going to be overlapping
themselves, so that we have
today talking about Malcolm
X from say, well his,
his biography essentially,
till his
assassination in sixty-five,
and then on Wednesday, we're
going to go back over the
time period between roughly
'63 and '65. It's the
simplest way that I know of
to make sure that we handle
a new understanding
of, of Malcolm X,
or maybe a
different understanding,
and also make sure we get
the events on the ground
that are happening at
the same time. So the
chronology's
overlapping. Okay,
with that
explanation out of the way,
let me begin with a sampling
of Malcolm X's famous
rhetoric, and this one
is following the March on
Washington. So we're
talking about now in August
of 1963. When asked about
the March on Washington,
Malcolm X
replied or giving a,
giving a speech--this is an
excerpt from "Message to the
Grassroots": "No,
it was a sellout.
It was a takeover.
When James Baldwin
came in from Paris,
they wouldn't let him talk,
because they couldn't make
him go by the script.
Burt Lancaster read the
speech that Baldwin was
supposed to make; they
wouldn't let Baldwin get up
there, because they know,
they know Baldwin's liable
to say anything.
They controlled it so tight
---- they told those Negroes
what time to hit
town, how to come,
where to stop,
what signs to carry,
what song to sing, what
speech they could make,
and what speech
they couldn't make;
and then told them to
get out town by sundown.
And every one of those Toms
was out of town by sundown.
Now I know you don't
like say--my saying this,
but I can, I can back it up.
It was a circus, a
performance that beat
anything
Hollywood could ever do,
the performance of the year.
(Walter Reuther, labor
leader) Walter Reuther and
those other three devils
should get a Academy Award
for the best actors because
they acted like they really
loved Negroes and fooled
a whole lot of Negroes.
And the six Negro leaders
should get an award too,
for the best
supporting cast."
It's quite a statement.
This is again from "Message
to the Grassroots," although
he would respond to other
people that the speech
was nothing but a circus on
other occasions, it's
delivered shortly before
Malcolm X breaks with the
Nation of Islam and Elijah
Muhammad. The
reading for this week,
one of the
readings,Malcolm X Speaks,
excerpts, a collection of,
of talks edited by George
Breitman, are all
ex--speeches from "Message
to the Grassroots" to the
end of Malcolm X's life,
a, a time period that's
rather important for reasons
you'll see as the course of
the lecture--over the course
of this lecture. Now
Malcolm X was famous for
rhetoric like referring to
the March on Washington as a
circus and for other,
other sort of notorious,
infamous statements. I want
to play a couple of other
excerpts, because there's
nothing like hearing the
person speaking. The first
is from--and I'll let the
two speeches run
together. You'll,
you'll notice the break,
definitely. The first is
from "The Ballot or the
Bullet" and the second is
from "The Black--The
Black Revolution."
[Malcolm X:] This is why I
say it's the ballot or the
bullet.
It's liberty or it's death.
It's freedom for everybody
or freedom for nobody.
America today finds herself
in a unique situation.
Historically,
revolutions are bloody.
Oh, yes, they are.
They haven't ever had a
bloodless revolution,
or a nonviolent revolution.
That don't happen
even in Hollywood.
You don't have a revolution
in which you love your
enemy, and you don't have a
revolution in which you are
begging the system of
exploitation to integrate
you into it.
Revolutions
overturn systems.
Revolution destroys systems.
A revolution is bloody,
but America is in a unique
position. She's the only
country in history in a
position actually to become
involved in a bloodless
revolution.
All she's got to do is
give the black man in this
country
everything that's due him,
everything.
I hope that the
white man can see this,
because if you don't
see it you're finished.
If you don't see it you're
going to become involved in
some action in which
you don't have a chance.
And we don't care anything
about your atomic bomb;
it's useless because other
countries have atomic bombs.
When two or three different
countries have atomic bombs,
nobody can use them, so it
means that the white man
today is without a weapon.
If you want some action, you
gotta come on down to Earth.
And there's more black
people on Earth than there
are white people on Earth.
It'll be--it'll be the,
the ballot or
it'll be the bullet.
It'll be liberty
or it'll be death.
And if you're not
ready to pay that price,
don't use the word
freedom in your vocabulary."
That's the end of the first
clip. And the second clip
begins right now.
[Malcolm X: ] "We
should defend ourselves.
And when I say we should
defend ourselves against the
violence of others, that
if they use their press
skillfully to make the world
think that I'm calling on
violence period, and I
wouldn't call on anybody to
be violent without a cause.
But I think the black
man in this country,
above and beyond
people all over the world,
will be more justified when
he stands up and starts to
protect himself, no matter
how many necks he has to
break or heads
he has to crack."
This is why I say it's
the ballot or the bullet.
So it's important to ask,
when thinking about Malcolm
X, and these--playing
these excerpts,
are we hearing a different
kind of voice? Are we
hearing a different
engagement or interpretation
with the present moment,
1964? Are we hearing a
different agenda? Is
this what makes Malcolm X so
different from Martin
Luther King and other famous
African American
leaders? Well,
you know by now that
what he's asking for in The
Ballot or the Bullet, the
excerpt from the speech The
Ballot or the Bullet, he's
asking for civil rights. He
says there's no need
for a bloody revolution,
certainly. All he's asking
is for that--for the black
man what is due him, he says
in the quote. Is he doing
something new when he's
asking for these things?
You can go back to the
Niagara Movement in 1905 and
hear a lot of the same kinds
of things that Malcolm X is
seeking. Okay now the
Niagara Movement wasn't
calling for
violence upon violence,
in, in response to
violence, self-defense,
not that way. So one
might say well he was doing
something new
there. But even then,
no. If you look back to
Robert Williams in the
1950s, head of the NAACP
chapter in North Carolina,
something I've already
brought up before and in
your reader, he was
calling for black men to,
you know, gather up
their arms and respond with
force. So Malcolm X is
talking really in a longer
tradition, certainly a long
tradition of calling for
full civil
rights and equality,
and, and speaking in a
long tradition as well,
although much less
talked about and much less
consistent really,
but always there,
about violent self-defense,
embracing violence,
if, if this
is--embracing self-defense,
and if that means
using violence,
so be it.
Now why is this lingering,
worth lingering over? It's
worth it because like
Martin Luther King,
Malcolm X's life is frozen
in time. We'll be coming
back next to King next week
and you'll--I'll flesh out
that statement more
completely. But like Martin
Luther King, Malcolm X is
frozen in time. And really
frozen in time incorrectly.
Malcolm X's life is
encapsulated by
just, you know,
the phrase "By any means
necessary." Certainly,
gosh, I can't remember
how many years ago now,
when Spike Lee's film
Malcolm X came out,
there was just an
amazing moment at the
commodification
of Malcolm X,
embodied in really cool
baseball caps with a white X
on the front, or in
t-shirt and such. And,
you know, that's how
you "kept it real,
by walking around town
wearing that kind of outfit,
wearing Malcolm X,
and his belief system,
allegedly with an
over--overpriced cap you're
wearing or the t-shirt.
The fact is that the
popularized, commodified
image of Malcolm X is also
one that's out of date.
In fact, by the
end of his life,
he was not even
known as Malcolm X,
and he distanced himself in
an incremental fashion from
a lot of his most famous
declarations in the early
1960s. So who is then
Malcolm X? Let's work
through the biography.
His birth name is Malcolm
Little. He was born in
1925. He's assassinated in
February 1965, less than a
year after he breaks from
the Nation of
Islam. Now this,
this little fact is
actually inconsequential,
but it is funny the way
we think about things,
that Martin
Luther King is the,
you know, middle
class, moderate,
grown-up and
Malcolm X, the fiery,
youthful ambassador to
the Nation of Islam,
in a sense.
But Malcolm X is older than
Martin Luther King by four
years.
I mean, yeah, it's
kind of inconsequential,
but it actually speaks to
the way in which we kind of
remember these people in our
minds. Both of them were
very young men. So Malcolm
Little is born in 1925.
He's known over the course
of his life as Detroit Red,
as Malcolm X most famously,
and finally as El-Hajj Malik
El-Shabazz. He's a
child, a middle child,
of eight.
His father's a
Baptist minister,
and an organizer for Marcus
Garvey's UNIA. There's
different versions about
Malcolm X's early life and
you know,
forgive me, I will,
I will often use
Malcolm X in this lecture,
just out of old habits.
There's not a whole bunch
about Malcolm Little's life.
His father has died, either
murdered by a Klan-styled
group in Michigan,
the Black Legionnaires,
or died an accidental
death. In either case,
Malcolm's fatherless
at age six. The family
disintegrates. Malcolm
Little drops out of school,
moves to Boston
and then to Harlem,
and becomes a hustler.
He's running numbers,
selling drugs, he's pimping,
and is a petty thief.
During this era in his life,
he's adopted the street
moniker as Detroit Red. At
twenty-one--and I've just,
and I've encapsulated, or
sort of put parentheses
around the first twenty-one
years of his life in just
that little biographical
sketch--at twenty-one,
he's arrested and sent to
prison for burglary and
larceny. He's given an
eight- to ten-year sentence
and ultimately serves six
and a half years. He's
paroled in 1952, about
twenty-seven years old.
While he's in prison, he
has a religious conversion.
He--while he's in prison,
he's converted to the Nation
of Islam, and adopts the
name Malcolm X. The X is a
reference to a long legacy
of African Americans who
were in an enslaved past who
were given the master's last
name. And X is a, is a
declaration that they are
wiping out the slave
name from their past,
and they're speaking
to an unknown past,
but claiming it as their
own. [student sneezes]
Bless you.
Anyway, Malcolm X, now, is
a member of the Lost Found
Nation of Islam in
the Wilderness of North
America. That's the full
name. The Lost Found Nation
of Islam in the Wilderness
of North America. It's a
religious sect founded by
a rather shadowy person,
we really don't know
much about him at all,
named Wallace Fard,
founded around 1930. Fard
disappears under curious
circumstances. I've never
seen anything
convince--convincing of what
actually happened to Fard,
but one of the people he
brought into his circle
before he disappears is a
janitor in
Detroit, Michigan,
in Detroit, Michigan named
Elijah Poole. Elijah Poole
becomes the spiritual
head of the religious
organization known as the
Nation of Islam and renames
himself Elijah Muhammad.
Now the Nation of Islam is a
very unorthodox version
of traditional Islam.
There's barely any
connection between the two
in truth, at least at that
moment in time. The Nation
of Islam grafts together
black nationalism and some
Islamic fundamentals.
Elijah Muhammad teaches,
through the Nation of
Islam, to his disciples,
his followers. That
Muhammad taught--excuse me,
I lost my place in my notes
here. Muhammad taught that
whites were a mutant
race of blue-eyed devils,
created by, created by a mad
black scientist to persecute
black people. As
the messenger of God,
Elijah Muhammad would free
his followers one day when
Allah's apocalyptic wrath
finally destroyed whites.
In the meantime,
the black Muslims,
followers of the
Nation of Islam,
the black Muslims would
offer hope to blacks through
self-discipline and
self-help. So the creation
myth revolves around a, a
crazed black scientist who
fashions whites to persecute
blacks. Just as bizarre as
any other creation
myth, I suppose,
that's out there. Anyway,
this is what it is. And
that black Muslims would,
would be the population to
help blacks through
this time of struggle,
through teaching
self-discipline and
self-help. This is one of
the reasons the Nation of
Islam is so
traditionally--been so
powerful at, or
so successful at,
converting people who
are in prison. Teaching
self-discipline
and self-help,
being those things that
are most desperately needed,
often, by those
who are in prison,
after all. Teaching
race pride as well,
independence. Anyway,
shortly after his release
from prison, Malcolm X meets
Elijah Muhammad and becomes
an assistant minister in
Detroit Temple Number One.
This is where the Nation is
headquartered. Malcolm X,
despite the interesting
ways he's been historicized,
one cannot deny the fact
that he's an incredibly
charismatic speaker,
powerful speaker. Elijah
Muhammad recognizes this and
very quickly sends Malcolm X
to, to Harlem, and
establishes him as the
minister of the Harlem
temple. And although it's
not the headquarters
of the Nation of Islam,
because it's in Harlem,
sort of black Manhattan,
it very quickly becomes the
most important temple. And
Elijah Muhammad asks, asks
Malcolm X to be his--the
national spokesman for
the Nation of Islam.
So very quickly, Malcolm X
goes from jail to meeting
Elijah Muhammad, to becoming
assistant minister at the
Detroit temple, to becoming
the head of the Harlem
temple, to becoming the
spokesman for the Nation of
Islam, although he's not
the head of the Nation of
Islam. Under Malcolm X's
charismatic leadership,
the Nation of Islam grows
exponentially. It's really
very small in the 1950s. It
grows from several hundred
followers to over ten
thousand by the early
1960s. Still rather small,
of course. As Malcolm X
continues to
speak and advocate,
the membership grows and new
temples are established.
Radio stations are
purchased. Stores are
opened up. The Nation of
Islam in their early 1960s,
late fifties, early sixties,
is tapping into a growing
disaffection
within black America,
particularly urban and
northern black America.
This is a movement that is
overwhelmingly northern at
this point in
time. The Steel Belt,
Steel Belt,
thinking along the,
the northern, middle
west of the United States,
Ohio and Pittsburgh,
heading across to Michigan,
is becoming the Rust Belt,
going through a period of
deindustrialization. The
jobs that caused blacks to
migrate north to the--after
the Second World War are
going away and they're stuck
in crumbling ghettoes.And
the rhetorical
flair of Malcolm,
I'm sorry, of Martin Luther
King's speeches--this is
also the period of King's
greatest triumphs--aren't
doing anything to
change the daily quality,
quality of life
for most blacks,
particularly those living
outside of the South. So if
you're stuck in a slum
apartment in Detroit,
Michigan or
Chicago, Illinois,
the powerful rhetoric that's
coming from King and the
struggles in
Birmingham, Montgomery,
and other places, they
aren't putting food on your
table, they aren't changing
what happens when you look
for a job. Malcolm X's
rhetoric isn't necessarily
putting food on the table,
but when you marry the
rhetoric with the
establishment of these
temples and stores,
Nation of Islam stores,
and laundries--if you think
back to Marcus Garvey's
UNIA,
black-owned, entrepreneurial
opportunities, serving a
black community--that's what
the Nation of Islam is
doing as well. If you tap
into--if, if you are, are
listening to Malcolm X's
rhetoric and
actually going to a temple,
then maybe going to a store,
you're finding yourself in a
community that will help
you. So Malcolm X and the
Nation of Islam are tapping
into something sort of
festering, disillusioned
urban slum dwellers.
There's growing skepticism
in black America about the
worth of integrating
into the white mainstream,
with James Baldwin
famously saying,
"Why would I want to
integrate into a burning
house?" There's a growing
increase in support for
violent methods to solve
problems and a surge in
nationalist sentiment among
African Americans not seen
since the Garvey years,
since the height of the
Garvey movement in the
nineteen-teens and the
1920s. All of these
things working together are
increasing the numbers
in the Nation of Islam,
developing a broader support
base. Now the Nation is a
religious organization and
was steadfast in its refusal
to get involved in
contemporary electoral
politics, very different
from Southern Christian
Leadership
Conference, for example,
SNCC, other organizations.
The Nation is a religious
organization. Had a very
conservative social view,
very much along the lines of
Booker T.
Washington's notions of
self-help. It is racially
separatist. It's not
embracing any of the
integrating logics of,
of SNCC at that point,
or NAACP, or other
groups. Malcolm X,
in fact, had represented
Elijah Muhammad in the
Nation in negotiations with
the national heads of the
KKK and the American Nazi
Party. Thinking back to
Marcus Garvey, believing
that the head of the Klan
was the most honest white
man in America. You have
the same kind of mentality
being expressed in the
Nation of Islam. But all is
not well with the Nation of
Islam either.
There are whisperings,
as we get into
the early 1960s,
that Elijah Muhammad and
the allegations he's having
affairs with teenage
members of the Nation,
whisperings he's actually
impregnated several members
of the Nation, and then
publicly rebuked the same
young women for fornication,
never naming himself in the
process and getting them
thrown out of the Nation.
There have been whisperings
for a long time about
financial improprieties, and
there's an increasing sense
of frustration,
certainly felt by Malcolm X,
but also by other
members of the Nation,
that coming down from Elijah
Muhammad is a steadfast
refusal to get involved in
the politics of the day.
There's also a tension
created by the fact that
Malcolm X is increasingly
popular and although he's
not the leader
of the Nation,
because he is the
spokesperson for the Nation,
he is seen as embodying the
Nation. So we're in 1963.
John F.
Kennedy is
assassinated in November,
and Malcolm X, because he is
such a prominent individual
in the Nation, was asked
what he thought about this
moment, this moment of
great national tragedy,
and white and black
Americans are devastated
that the seeming prince of a
person had been cut down.
And Malcolm X
very famously says,
"It was merely a case of
the chickens coming home to
roost." That's a response
that Malcolm X meant to use
to highlight the fact
that JFK lived by the sword,
and he was quite a
saber-rattler as a
President, that he lived by
the sword and therefore he
was going to die by it.
Whether Malcolm X's comment
made any sense or not, it
was a comment that horrified
the country. Elijah
Muhammad saw this as an
opportunity, as it
turns out. He is getting
feedback,
whisperings as well,
that Malcolm X is
becoming too popular,
that Malcolm X is, is
growing away from the Nation
and from Elijah Muhammad.
Elijah Muhammad is concerned
about his ability to control
Malcolm X.So Muhammad jumps
on this opportunity and
silences Malcolm X for
ninety days, based on that
comment. He was not allowed
to represent the Nation of
Islam and not to speak on
the Nation's behalf. Now
from a standpoint of public
policy, it made
perfect sense. I mean,
this is such a, a
moment of anger,
folks on the
Nation of Islam,
that to have anything
less than silenced Malcolm X
would have been, would have
been seen as to support this
notion of chickens coming
home to roost. But the
truth really does lie
elsewhere in terms of Elijah
Muhammad's anxiety, growing
anxiety about Malcolm X and
his popularity, and
also because Malcolm X had
confronted Muhammad
about his affairs,
that he'd heard that these
things were happening. He
was waiting for Elijah
Muhammad to refute them,
and he never could.
Financial improprieties,
he couldn't refute
those either. During this
moratorium, this
ninety day silence,
it becomes clear to
Malcolm X that his silence,
his ban on public speaking
would not be lifted,
and so he breaks from
the Nation of Islam. His
speech, "Message
to the Grassroots,
which I spoke from at the
beginning of the lecture,
it's one of the last
speeches he gives before he
breaks from the Nation.
And if you look back at it,
you can see sort of the
handwriting on the wall,
because peppered throughout
Malcolm X's declarations
would be, you know, that
he speaks on behalf of the
honorable Elijah Muhammad.
"As the honorable Elijah
Muhammad says,"
"The honorable,
honorable Elijah Muhammad
believes" this that and the
other. He can't say
it in this speech.
He's growing apart. So the
split becomes official in
March of 1964. Malcolm X
establishes a religious
organization called the
Muslim Mosque Incorporated,
and a political organization
called the Organization of
Afro-American
Unity, thus reflecting,
or creating, this
two-headed--or maybe these
two organizations on, on
separate paths. Certainly
embodying a belief by
Malcolm X that broad social
engagement provided blacks
the best chance for ending
racism, not just a set of
personal belief systems,
but also engaging the battle
on the ground. This was the
political
aspect of the OAAU,
the Organization,
Organization of
Afro-American Unity that
Malcolm X felt was lost--a
lost opportunity for the
Nation of Islam. Before
establishing the OAAU,
Malcolm X makes a hajj,
a religious
journey to Mecca,
and during that trip has a
stunning change of heart on
race relations.
Very famously in the
Autobiography of Malcolm
X, written by Alex Haley,
you see Malcolm X talking
about meeting Muslims who
were whiter than the whitest
person he'd seen in the
United States, blue eyes and
blond hair. He had a very
sort of immature
notion of what traditional
Muslim--Islamic faith was
like and what Muslims would,
quote, "look like," even.
So whites are no longer the
blue-eyed devil in
Malcolm X's view.
His outlook, his
political, religious,
and ethical outlook, which
certainly is revolutionary
while he's with
the Nation of Islam,
becomes increasingly
anti-capitalist. And this
is something
we're going to see,
not just in Malcolm
X's belief system,
but in other
leaders' belief systems,
as we head into the mid and
late 1960s. Anti-capitalist
thinking and rhetoric
becomes much more important
and is certainly a string
that ties a lot of these
individuals together,
although that linkage is
often not talked about. He
rejects his prior views on
race. He rejects the
idea of black separatism.
He rejects his
anti-Semitism. He rejects
his opposition to
intermarriage. All of these
are views that he espoused
while in the Nation of
Islam. He comes to
recognize that women
actually did have an
important role to play in
the political struggle. And
he begins to accept and look
for--accept the idea of and
look for alliances of black
organizations with
other groups committed to
revolutionary change.
This is a complete change of
heart. His
prior views on race,
race separatism, his, his
notion of the role Jews
played in the world system,
his anti-Semitic views,
his opposition
to intermarriage,
all of those are gone.
Women might have a role in
the struggle. Whites are no
longer blue-eyed devils.
There could be other
organizations
blacks could relate to,
attach themselves to, as
long as they're working
towards revolutionary
change. In the end,
Malcolm X acknowledged
that his political views are
rapidly evolving, embodied
in the fact that he no
longer goes by Malcolm X.
El-Hajj Malik El-Shabazz is
the name he adopts during
this last conversion. He
admits, El-Hajj
Malik El-Shabazz,
that--when asked, that he
was hard-pressed to give a
specific definition of the
overall philosophy which he
thought was necessary for
the liberation of black
people in the United
States. He didn't know at
this point what the right
answer was. This is between
middle of '64 and early
1965. Now Malcolm X is
assassinated in February
of 1965 by members of the
Nation of Islam.
There's been rumor mills
running nonstop since then
about who was really
behind the assassination,
I mean, beyond the folks
who actually pulled the
triggers. But was it a
man now known as Louis
Farrakhan, someone
scrambling for attention
from Elijah Muhammad, who
inspired or gave directions
to the, the, the murderers?
Was it the FBI infiltrating
the NOI, to find a way
to assassinate Malcolm X,
El-Hajj Malik El-Shabazz,
although he's no longer part
of the Nation of Islam?
The debate's been going on
really, I mean, through
the very recent past,
during bizarre sets of
events that leads to some
sort of
reconciliation, I suppose,
with Louis Farrakhan and
Malcolm X's--one of his
daughters or
grand?--must be daughters,
I suppose, and Louis
Farrakhan saying that,
you know, he apologizes if
someone had misinterpreted
his views or ideas in such a
way that they might--thought
it might be okay to
assassinate Malcolm X,
one of these squirrelly kind
of apologies. Fact of the
matter remains
that Malcolm X,
El-Hajj Malik El-Shabazz,
is murdered February 1965.
What does he leave behind?
He leaves behind no great
leadership legacy,
but in terms of,
you know, what
organization was left,
what did he do, he'd broken
from the organization that
had defined
most of his life,
his adult life. The
OAAU and the Muslim Mosque
Incorporated at the moment
of his assassination were
really inchoate. His views
were shifting. He couldn't
answer the question, what
is going to be the most
successful means to
liberating black Americans?
He didn't know the
answer. But we,
you know, it's, even
though he leaves no clear
leadership legacy behind,
can he be judged by normal
standards of his
leadership--by normal
standards of
leadership? His martyrdom,
as it turns out,
gives him--gave him his
legitimacy. Critics have
said that his emotionalism,
his powerful
rhetoric, that he,
he relied on it to win
his cases and it's also an
emotionalism that,
four years down the line,
three and four
years down the line,
lent themselves perfectly
well to the orthodoxies of
the late 1960s, something
we'll see in next week's
reading, Eldridge Cleaver,
Soul on Ice. So his ideas
were, you know,
the, the, you know,
the phrase is
sort of nonsensical,
you know, a person
ahead of his time,
the ideas that
become popularized,
that were popular when
Malcolm X was alive,
become popularized
after his death,
become the vehicle for
establishing sort of a
logic, organizational
logic, for groups,
that really don't even exist
when Malcolm X is alive.
Now martyrdom, certainly a
major element of the civil
rights movement. In
the time that remains,
I want to actually
segue from this Malcolm X
biography and, because we
have so much to cover on
Wednesday, shift gears a
little bit and start talking
about events going backward
over the last couple of
years of Malcolm X's
life, that spring from the,
the phenomenon, the
phenomena of martyrdom,
what it does for people, or
for a race in this case.
This is an era of
martyrdom, you have Kennedy
assassinated, November 22nd,
1963. Then Johnson's now
the President and calls
for the earliest possible
passage of the
Civil Rights Act,
something that was simmering
on the table at the moment
of John F.
Kennedy's assassination.
And Johnson commits himself
for the rest of his time
in office to fulfilling
Kennedy's legacy on this
agen--on this score. That's
in sixty-three.
Little earlier than that,
before Kennedy was
assassinated--and this gets
us to, if time permits,
right to this moment of
this, a
sec--another martyrdom,
the Students--Student
Nonviolent Coordinating
Committee, SNCC,
starts working on voter
registration drives and
organizes with other,
with other, gathers together
with other organizations to
have what's
called a freedom vote,
the fall of '63. Plans are
developed '62 for the fall
of '63, with the
goal of proving,
one, that blacks are
interested in voting. This
is all happening
in Mississippi,
an important fact
I just left out.
I just remembered, sorry.
The goal is to prove that
blacks are interested in
voting and to develop the
practice for the
eventual day when blacks in
Mississippi might
get the right to vote,
helping develop the culture
of voting for blacks in
Mississippi. This
turns into Freedom Summer,
1964. So now again
we're back after King's
assass--Kennedy's
assassination. The goal of
the Freedom Summer of '64
is to organize a real party,
the Mississippi
Freedom Democratic Party,
to establish freedom schools
throughout Mississippi,
sites literally of training
Mississippi youth the basics
of education, literacy being
one of the basic elements of
freedom schools, but also
creating community centers
for poor blacks to
come to get food,
to get clothing, and
also to develop a political
consciousness about the
future--about the present,
thinking about the future.
In June of '64, June 20th,
first wave of recruits comes
down to help make Freedom
Summer a reality. It's
people your age, people
from Yale who are your age,
are among the
recruits, quite famously,
a lot of them, coming
from college campuses in the
North and the Midwest
and the West coast,
coming to Mississippi to
try to create real change in
Mississippi, in, in
Mississippi. On June 21st,
the day after Mississippi
Freedom Summer begins,
three workers disappear,
Freedom Party workers.
Andrew Goodman, a
twenty-year-old from New
York City,
Michael Schwerner,
a twenty-five-year-old
from Brooklyn,
and James Chaney, a
twenty-one-year-old black
Mississippian. Two white
men and one black man.
They're
arrested for speeding,
a fairly common offense used
by the police. Speeding,
you know it didn't matter
what speed you were actually
going; they just arrested
you for it. They were
released that night,
but understanding that,
in Mississippi, they're
dealing with infrastructure
of police terror.
The organizers for the
meet--Mississippi Freedom
Summer had a process that if
you, if you get
arrested at all,
that you check in. If
you're out in the field,
you check in at
normal intervals. Well,
Goodman, Schwerner and
Chaney did not check in at
the appointed time, or
within fifteen minutes of
the appointed time.
This sends out alarms.
Compressing a lot
of history here,
but based on
their disappearance,
LBJ sends in
sailors, Navy divers,
to start
drag--dredging swamps,
looking for Schwerner,
Goodman and Chaney. There's
no doubt that they were
killed. They've just go to
find them now. What is
quite horrific in the
process of
looking for Schwerner,
Goodman and Chaney is that
the divers don't find them,
but they start pulling up
other black bodies that had
long gone missing in
Mississippi and in other
states. Quite a state of
affairs. During the summer,
up in Washington, D.C.,
there's frantic attempts to
organize the Congress, to
break filibusters in the
Senate, to get the civil
rights bill signed into
law. And on
July 2nd, in 1964,
Lyndon Johnson, Lyndon
Johnson succeeds. It's the
most far reaching civil
rights bill in history at
that point, and it gives the
attorney general tremendous
power. And the
power, essentially,
to enforce what is
already on the books in many
places. It provides for
full access in places of
public accommodation,
establishes a permanent
Equal Employment Opportunity
Commission. It says there's
going to be no
discrimination in federally
funded programs, something
that really becomes
important, I mean it's
important immediately,
but becomes part of the
debate in the--up to our
present day, in fact.
Now the Civil Rights Act
signed into law in July '64,
it's largely irrelevant to
Mississippi blacks. Despite
all the work of the
Mississippi Freedom Summer
activists, and their
success at establishing the
Mississippi Freedom
Democratic Party,
essentially an alternative
to the Democratic Party in
Mississippi, the fact is,
the chance for blacks to
actually vote
through, quote,
"normal channels,"
"official channels,
is essentially
nonexistent. Still in the
summer, Schwerner,
Goodman and Chaney have been
disappeared, the civil
rights bill is passed but is
meaningless to Mississippi.
There are fights within
Mississippi's
state delegation,
within the state government,
about trying to silence the
Mississippi Freedom
Democratic Party. Democrats
are heading towards a
convention in August for the
Democratic Party. The
question is bubbling about
what is going to
happen in Mississippi,
which group of delegates
are going to be recognized.
Will it be the official
delegates of the Democratic
Party in Mississippi or will
it be the delegates of the
Freedom Democratic Party?
LBJ is facing a threat that
five other southern states
would walk away if the
Democratic Party--from the
convention if the Democratic
Party from Mississippi,
the "official delegation,
is not seated at
the convention.
And on August 4th, three
weeks before the convention,
the bodies of Schwerner,
Goodman and Chaney are found
in an earthen dam,
near Philadelphia,
Mississippi. Philadelphia,
Mississippi. The bodies are
riddled with thirty-eight
caliber bullets.
Chaney, sole black
man, his head is,
I'm sorry, his skull is
fractured. He had suffered
a savage beating.
Mississippi law refused to
allow the three men to be
buried side by
side, as they wished,
as their families wished.
Chaney had to be buried in a
segregated
cemetery. Eventually,
twenty-one
whites are arrested,
including the
deputy sheriff,
all released by a
state court. Eventually,
six put on--into jail for
violating federal civil
rights laws, are given three
to six years. David Dennis,
the head of
Mississippi's CORE,
the Congress of
Racial Equality,
when asked to give a
eulogy for James Chaney,
agrees to do so and to give
a calming eulogy. When he
gets in front of the crowd,
in this moment of profound
emotional turmoil
and political turmoil,
wrestling with the martyrdom
of these three men,
he snaps and says something
quite off the script,
and that's exactly where
we'll pick up on Wednesday.